got to be a joker he just do
what he please
are you kidding me claim the [ __ ] are
you ready
sorry i was trying to do everyone met a
thing because coming together was on the
justice league trailer
greg's wearing his hair down today
because long-haired joker is back in
fashion
so my morning was i got a text from
bradley bledsoe
saying did you check out that new joker
image and i was like
what so i saw only like this tiny tiny
tiny photo from before was god
dawg i gotta wait till the camera's
pointing at us there's this article here
and uh we'll go through it we'll break
it down so they talk about the
description there's an interview with
zack snyder
there's a scene description the full on
scene description here we're gonna go
through all of it but first
we gotta look at the photo here's a
screenshot of all i've seen
here's the rest of this all i have right
here yeah there it is right there
let's do the unveiling drum roll okay
let me just zoom out here
whoa he's got a marilyn manson thing
going on about him and now that's who he
wants from
now it's just a natural reaction no he
really does
though i mean i guess the unfortunate
fact that he has that same
gaunt look and sneaky hair creepy yeah
it's really eerie especially with the
creepy the lipstick goes beyond his
mouth and suggests i'm not comparing the
character to marilyn manson
although he is kind of abusive
they're not that far apart and i mean
he's abusive to pretty much everyone in
his organization which seems to be
playing the villainous role but we're
not here to talk about that and then we
got another photo here
damn oh i'm loving this i like his weird
smock where's his face tattoos they're
under
my mom that's the only one who wanted to
face that
you want him to still be damaged i know
i'm with you
that is scary yeah that is he's got a
hospital gown on
he's like doing some messed up surgical
procedure stuff isn't he
yeah he really is all my guest
running all my guesses before we go
through the article here
but i love it it's so sinister he's got
scarves on his face
i don't know how i got these scars well
with the black and white and everything
it just looks like his eyes and mouth
are just
big old black holes you know they're
sunken in and it's yeah really
nightmarish
oh i'm loving this i'm really
really hoping as short as it might be in
the movie i'm hoping it serves as some
type of redemption for
the backlash that happened for jared
leto for suicide squad because yeah i
mean
we're both on record as not being big
fans of that movie but john and i tend
to be optimists i'm rooting
for him in this situation i really am
very very much rude that he's going to
pull this off
this looks sinister this looks sadistic
it looks badass
let's start going through the article
man that is a creepy ass change the more
you look at it the more you're like
that's gonna be a great halloween
costume
staring into the depths of your soul you
know what what i love about this
i'm not thinking of jared leto when i
see this photo
no i'm thinking of joker before i was
thinking of jared leto playing joker
even from the first image the ha that
one
yeah this one i'm just thinking of jared
button i'm thinking of joker i'm not
thinking of a choice
jared leto made i'm just thinking of
like damn that looks like a striking
image of
yeah that looks great i'm excited
let's go through this all right gone are
the face tattoos and slick back
emerald undercut hairstyle at that movie
replaced by a visage
that looks like a creature who crawled
the basement of a long abandoned insane
asylum
what asylum could that be oh don't know
leto is wearing a hospital gown and
surgical mask
yes which the director says is probably
a remnant of the uh
uh he's saying probably probably a
remnant of his escape into the wild when
the world fell it's probably this
i don't know why i chose it but it's
probably it's cool right yeah
it looks neat lettuce joker also
supports a bulletproof vest
festoon with grimmy law enforcement
badges he has a ton of badges those are
his trophies
what do you see that here not on this
photo no you don't
so the badges are just the law
enforcement his main thing is killing
cops
gcpd i'm assuming he goes on to tell of
a vanity fair he wants a variety the
joker is really the only thing that i
thought of in retrospect
but i will say that it always was my
intention to bring joker into that world
all right now we got a scene to go
through apparently it says spoiler
warning
i've never seen an article on an
entertainment site be like
spoiler warning we're about to give you
a scene for one of the best that
hasn't ever been shown yet from this
movie
and greg and john are gonna go through
it right now so if you want no spoilers
of what this scene is click away joker
appears in the new film
during a sequence set on a ruin earth
after the alien tyrant
dark side invades and decimates the
planet
it's a dream sequence a psychic vision
experienced by ben affleck's bruce wayne
that reveals what will happen if the
superheroes fail to stop the onslaught
oh so we're not going to the actual
apocalypse so
it's like a part of his nightmare yeah
like how there's a nightmare sequence in
bvs
okay that's telling because i didn't
know if we were going to actually
go into the apocalypse who justice
league he's gonna be riding on
steppenwolf's back
joker is sort of the ghost of christmas
yet to come supplying motivation
through terror cool the cool thing about
the scene is that it's
joker talking directly to batman about
batman
ah yeah i'm sure something something
jared leto's always wanted to do is he
got to play joker
it's joker analyzing batman about who he
is and what he is
that's the thing i also feel like fans
deserve from the dc universe that is to
say
the jared leto joker and the ben affleck
batman that never really got together
deceived yeah
you know what that is that is true that
was one benefit of the doubt i was also
giving okay maybe i wasn't a big fan of
suicide squad maybe i didn't really
care for jared leto's joker in that
particular cut that we got
hashtag release the haircut i did wonder
what if he did pair up with ben
affleck's batman
would it have been better now i feel
like it would have been around from an
acting standpoint
from a character's damage especially
with the two variations and their
personalities it might have been really
neat
it seemed uncool to me that we would
make it all the way through this
incarnation of batman and joker without
seeing them come together
come together i didn't even know he was
gonna say that
schneider already had a history devise
in his head the scene explains why
bruce had the joker card taped to his
gun that you see in bvs
okay cool which also hinted that the
joker
murdered the caped crusader sidekick by
showing the epson robin's armor spray
painted with
haha jokes on you batman haha joke's on
you batman
i'd always wanted to explore the death
of robin if there was going to be a next
movie which of course there probably
won't be
as he says publicly negotiating i wanted
to do a thing
where in flashbacks we learn how robin
died how joker killed him and
burned down wayne manor and the
whole thing that happened between he and
bruce
oh so in the apocalypse moment when
wayne manor is
is to rubble are we assuming now that
that was a joker
but he killed robin at a difference
what time did wayne manner burn down
exactly or is there something i'm
forgetting right now this very morning
about something in bvs that talked about
having to rebuild wayne manor at one
point let me know down below but
i might just be blanking on something
the director's plan was to show how they
became like this how he hurt him in a
way that no one has really
other than losing his parents is
probably the most significant personal
injury to his life
you know what's funny this guy's saying
there probably won't be another movie
yet he's like slowly saying but if there
was another movie
i don't have really any ideas but i know
i would want to do it this way
that's the role this new joker secrets
will fulfill in justice league but those
seeking continuity may have questions
what happened since we last saw this
joke or nader's film is there tattoo
removal in the apocalypse how disturbing
would it be if he did it himself and why
did he do it i would say that there's
been some water under the bridge who
knows what's happened
i don't know if he's wearing makeup i
don't know what's happening it's hard to
say exactly
what is going on when he talks about it
it just looked cool this way damn it
simultaneously hurting and helping your
kids
in situations like this where you're
like yeah man it looks cool i don't
really know why
but you know here's maybe why it could
also be artistic subconscious expression
to give a benefit of the doubt there
sometimes we always want the clear-cut
y answers on things but a lot of times
like he's a very visual director he
might just have like these certain
visual aesthetic
in mind yeah of what to do and it's not
really about
the why and leaving that a little bit
even ambiguous in his mind until he
further explores it down the road yeah
or he doesn't know what he's talking
about it's gonna be one of them too i
mean but i i
actually would all jokes aside i would
reckon that it would probably be the
former over the latter
you can interpret that to me and snyder
just liked it better this way
after all that i mean it's a little bit
of both okay you call them eggs
well you never know exactly ambiguity is
a big part of the creativity even the
article promoting this is like
i think you just liked it better the
version of justly will exist on its own
making use of some material from other
dc movies but standing alone as a kind
of else world's tale well i'm excited
for it this all sounds
awesome this sounds exciting can't wait
to watch it
trailer this sunday keep a lookout
subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button leave your thoughts down
about g
leto down below last but not least
john take it away oh andrew hayes you
know what
usually on wolverine related videos i
think of you but now
since you got your sexy pandemic long
hair i feel like this is the time
to change my association with you and
comic books get a different
universe associated with you so now
you're my joker buddy
plus you're in a band now you play music
you're getting like new instruments left
and right
paint your face up man do the whole goth
thing that's the next phase of an
race that i really want to see um but
yeah
it's fascinating watching you do this
you're trying to like link it to the
video
you're also trying to point out like
facts about the guy
well i guess this is really interesting
i'm just like why are you trying to do a
lot of one strange trying to tailor it
to you
but also it matches the video i don't
know
[Music]
but
[Music]